[Music]
so my next guest is one of my favorite
comedians in comedy I love them so much
you may know him from HBO's enlightened
and the league on FXX
please welcome my friend the hilarious
Jason Mantzoukas everybody
[Applause]
well you see what people don't know is
we were discussing backstage in the old
green room oh yeah these are industry
terms oh yeah yeah the green room andrew
is not green by the way not a green room
we went into one room the first room we
went into very smelly there's a problem
something always there yeah yeah yeah oh
I hadn't noticed
normally notice oh you you were
employing sorry Ken yeah yeah yeah we
walked right in it was like oh no smell
terribly yeah you know how sometimes I
feel like TV shows pretend to be like
low-budge yeah and you're like things
are falling apart we really have a room
that smells straight-up like yeah
in that way that I feel like I'm
guessing I can only assume like Lucille
Ball took a in that room and it is
just haunted it is just like a haunted
back in the day you know I mean
right now well we were talking about how
you like to come out yeah double-double
bird double bird to the RT of the
audience that's a thing yeah yeah it
really takes the temperature of the
audience real quick if you give an
audience a double bird and they're like
yeah we are on board for this yeah great
show if you give the double bird to the
audience and they're like what now what
I'm sorry sir no thank you
yeah it's gonna be a tough night it's
gonna be tough not if you're not on
board with that yeah cuz you're not
gonna like what's coming this is where
it begins yeah
sewer begin these are two rectal
thermometer yes again they're good
tonight
I mean that's one way to put it
what's the last time you put something
in your butt I mean honestly the last
time I had something in my butt was like
my whatever my most recent physical was
yeah
slowly losing slowly losing no they're
still there this
[Music]